hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be a Marvel Avengers age of Ultron
spider-man video but because the agent
Carter finale just happened I'm just
gonna jam those videos together so I'm
gonna start with the spider-man stuff
first so the really cool news is is that
Danny Elfman is writing music for
Avengers age of Ultron I know this is
weird his name appears on the poster
they just released why is his name on
the poster
Bryan Tyler scored the film so wait for
it drumroll obviously probably gonna be
a spider-man post-credit scene that
Danny Elfman is writing spider-man music
for for those that don't remember Danny
Elfman wrote the original spider-man
music for the Tobey Maguire films they
still use that score it's the one that
everyone remembers Brian Tyler's dead
music for a lot of Marvel films but
Danny Elfman did a lot of amazing music
for the DC Warner Brothers films my two
favourite Danny Elfman tracks are the
Batman that Michael Keaton Batman theme
that they kept using through the
animated series and his original
spider-man theme if you haven't heard
them they're on Spotify right now so you
can actually listen to them for free
there's no confirmation on whether or
not they've actually found our
spider-man the new actor that's gonna
play spider-man but it seems like
spider-man at least in a mask is going
to appear at the end of Avengers age of
Ultron in like a really short scene
there'll be multiple post-credits scenes
in spider-man will be one of those it's
totally unexpected
I'm really excited it's probably one of
the best surprises that we could have
heard about Marvel has been releasing
posters for age of Ultron like one a day
counting down so when they released the
final one they'll probably make an
announcement about that spider-man or
released a new trailer you guys can let
me know how you feel about the idea of a
spider-man post-pregnancy in age of
Ultron I think I think it would give us
a look at what his costume is gonna look
like at least even if we don't see the
actors face while you guys think about
that careful for spoilers for agent
Carter I'm just gonna go through my top
five moments and give my thoughts about
where season two is headed they haven't
confirmed season two but it's a pretty
safe bet they're gonna get a season two
so starting with number five Howard
Stark returns I have to say the editing
on this show is great I always like it
when characters enter a scene finishing
other characters sentences and the
thought that Howard Stark thinks the
White House security sucks the whole
point of this though was to explain what
really happened at the battle of finow
what the deal with midnight oil is
basically what happened is is he was
trying to create stark level nodos for
soldiers so they wouldn't have to sleep
and things went crazy the American
general Howard Stark was working with
stoles research
sit on the Russians and it ended up
killing fennhoff brother and all their
comrades it makes this revenge story a
little bit more personal so I like the
way they tied it back around to that but
I feel like they buried the lede a
little bit moving on to number four
fennhoff explains to Howard Stark why
he's punishing him so I saw a lot of
parallels between what's going on
between fennhoff and stark and Ultron
and Tony Stark in Avengers age of Ultron
or you could say the Avengers in general
fennhoff is upset that his brother died
he blames Howard Stark because in his
mind stark doesn't think about the
consequences of his actions
he creates weapons of mass destruction
and chaos and he wants justice for that
he wants to punish him Ultron's hatred
of Tony Stark and the Avengers in age of
Ultron is a little bit different but it
but it's pretty close he wants to punish
the Avengers because he perceives them
as being super high on themselves and
not willing to take responsibility for
the missteps of humanity obviously yeah
that's like a hundred fifty million
dollar movie and it's a little more
cat's in the cradle
because Finn - Howard Stark have no
familial relationship but you get the
idea
Dottie and Finn Hoffs characters are
really interesting narrate what's going
on in their heads so we do find out
where they're coming from
psychologically they're both really
twisted but in just like slightly
different ways moving on to number three
fennhoff and Dottie explained there's
this really interesting difference
between fennhoff and Dottie when they're
talking about New York City is an idea
fennhoff isn't quote unquote marvel of
American ingenuity and what it's built
with it's accomplished New York is a
testament to the idea that america is
the land of opportunity and you could do
anything you want that's why he wants
Howard Stark to be responsible for
destroying it Howard Stark represents
the American ideal he wants everyone to
realize that there's a negative side to
that Dottie on the other hand seems like
she wants to tear it all down because
New York Peggy Carter the SS are all
represent things that she can't have in
people that she can't be it's like she's
trying to fill a hole inside herself by
boring a hole in piggy skull so it's
kind of like Marvel's version of haters
gonna hate moving on to number two
fennhoff brainwashes Howard Stark and he
thinks that he's rescuing Captain
America this is a lot of fun I always
like these dream sequences that fennhoff
gets the logic is kind of fuzzy because
supposedly people are reliving dreams
that they've had but based on the way
they explained fennhoff powers I suppose
he could create things inside their
minds but he's basically manipulating
Howard Starks subconscious and conscious
minds at the same time
that shield that Peggy had went whenever
she walked into the scene that's the
actual shield that they used in Avengers
age of Ultron the one they had on set
here especially colored but sometimes
whenever they filmed with the shield
what they'll do is it'll be like a tone
down color version and then they'll add
all that like silver and red and those
really bright colors in post-production
really fun Easter Egg too after they
filmed the first Captain America movie
they actually they gave that Captain
America shield that he had in that to
Stephen Colbert so he has like the real
deal first Captain America shield the
thing I really like about this Howard
Stark scene is it humanizes him it's
like in the first Avengers film whenever
Tony Stark flies into the portal with a
warhead it's their way of atoning for
all the crap that they put everyone
through and even though we've only seen
a little bit of him it does seem like
Howard Stark isn't quite as high on
himself as Tony Stark
to be fair though if Howard Stark were
to make himself like an Iron Man suit
and fly around he'd probably get super
high on himself too I think the best way
to describe Howard Stark is constantly
preoccupied preoccupied with women
preoccupied with technology I really
like the Trinity that they have going on
between him and Peggy's so hopefully
Dominic Cooper will come back for season
two if they get renewed and of course my
number one moment
post-credits scene with Arnim Zola so
here's what the producers explained
after the fact fennhoff is now
officially connected to the Winter
Soldier program and now he's also part
of Hydra Zola unofficially inducks him
into Hydra agent Carter always trying to
loop back with the Captain America films
usually it's the first Captain America
film but obviously this loops back to
Winter Soldier
I think what'll happen in future seasons
is we'll just see like less and less
Captain America stuff they included a
lot of Captain America scenes in this
series I always loved the integration
with the movies but I think over time
what they're gonna try and do is make
agent Carter so that it can stand on its
own so that it won't need all those
Avengers scenes as for a Captain America
blood you can make as many superfish
jokes as you want she poured it off the
Brooklyn Bridge so if there was any
marine life down there they might I got
some extra juice but I'm not sure
anything can live in the East River
if you've never lived in New York the
East River is where they make all the
jokes about dead bodies getting dumped
it's like one of the dirtiest bodies of
water in New York so odds are nothing is
living down there so she should be fine
cut the season to when a fish crawls out
of the water looking kind of like
Captain America let me know that what
was your favorite moment and if they do
get a season two what do you want to see
them do next like
what storyline do you want to see them
do just to explain what's going on with
that Marvel isn't in control of whether
or not it gets a season two that's ABC's
job I saw a lot of people tweeting at
Marvel they're like hey we want you to
renew it but Marvel has nothing to do
with it they want a season two just as
bad as you do
ABC is the one that has to say okay yeah
we're ordering more episodes if they do
there's a lot of logical jumping-off
places like they just left a lot of
hanging threads on purpose like Dottie
escaped so she's gonna come back
Piggy and Angie now living at Howard
Stark's house Jarvis probably to come
back and help them Howard Stark probably
show up every once in a while to I think
one thing I was kind of disappointed by
in this season that I'm hoping we see in
season two is the creation of shield
shield was actually created in 1946
that's the year that this show takes
place so because they didn't show it
it's hard to tell whether or not they're
changing the timeline or if they're just
fudging on how long this was from like
start to finish it seems like the show
like from episode 1 to episode 8 took
place in like a relatively small time
frame like a matter of weeks I would
expect this season 2 would pick up
within like a couple weeks or a couple
of months of that so we're still in 1946
for those that are asking about
Leviathan so here's what I think was
going on they kind of fudged what was
going on with that a little bit in the
comics Leviathan is a Russian
organization it's like the Russian
version of Hydra on the show they made
it seem like that did exist fennhoff was
a part of it it's a part of a Russian
military organization but fin off
himself was working on his own so be
like Red Skull in acting a big Hydra
plan and Arnim Zola going off and doing
his own thing for a little bit that's
why they might do some more Leviathan
stuff in season 2 but because Arnim Zola
appeared and now Finn Huff's gonna be
part of Hydra they might start leaning
into Hydra a little bit I think it's
more likely that if agent Carter is
gonna get season 2 season 3 they'll
start to jump back and forth more
between agents of shield but for those
that are wondering Peggy Carter is going
to be in Avengers age of Ultron I don't
know if it's gonna be a flashback or a
hallucination because there will be
flashbacks like Captain America will
flashback to the 1940s but I don't know
if that's gonna be a fantasy sequence or
if it'll be stuff that actually did
happen for those that are asking I have
no idea of Toby Jones would be in a
future season of agent Carter it mean
it's possible he might get cameos but it
just depends on who they want to make
the main villain of the season what I
really like to see them do is go back to
Vanko and do a Crimson Dynamo storyline
that
be really awesome so in related news
arrow episode 15 is tonight they're
going to Nanda Parbat gonna be big
Rachele Ghul storyline so be sure to
subscribe to get that video I'll post it
after the episode airs I haven't done my
flash bonus video yet so I'll probably
post that tomorrow just so I have enough
time to do it
I just got some new audio gear that I'm
really excited about I'm not using it on
this video but hopefully I'll have it
hooked up by the time I do my arrow
video so hopefully this will sound nicer
while you guys wait for air tonight you
can click here to catch up and you can
click here for all my agent Carter
videos thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you